hot breath he says your jokes seem
conversational
which i guess that ties into your rhythm
your song is your
conversational style so with it being
more conversational do you have a
writing partner that you talk things out
with
no i'll try sometimes with just for my
friends i mean i don't have someone
specifically
uh but i'll call comics and be like you
know my the guy that opens with me like
brian bates like me and him talk a lot
because it's funny and then i'll say it
i kind of know before the joke ever hits
the stage if it's funny or not
i've i've like thought about it enough
and the older you
the longer you do comedy you can tell
when you're like i've never been a guy
i don't throw every joke on stage i
would see a lot of guys do that
when people would always be like you
know i remember going on the road we'd
do like a show
and then we'd go do some other like
local show
and they're like i'll just do this new
stuff i've never tried and i never
understood that because i was like
i just did all my new stuff on the state
like i don't i never have just like
20 minutes of jokes sitting on the
sideline
everything that i think of is out there
maybe there's new ideas i haven't put in
to play yet
but it's not many i mean i don't have
like a surplus
of just you know i have a book of just
50 ideas right that i've never tried
everything that i try everything that i
come up with it's
either i'm trying to put it in my act at
that moment
or it's gone or like i won't do it again
maybe i think of it again later
on uh but like it's i don't just sit
and have this stuff like sitting on the
sideline everything
everything goes up there and to keep
stuff conversational
a great way to do it is to either like
when you do radio interviews and you got
to be funny
during radio interviews like what they
tell you you got to do your act
like be funny like that's a you know
you're trying not to do your act
straight up
and then also just tell it see if you
can put it in a conversation
with some friends and stuff great way
for it to learn to be conversational
so you don't sound like you're just
doing your stand-up like you know at a
party
you just kind of like try to like you
know it's basically like you're telling
someone hey is this funny
and then you kind of tell them and then
see what their reaction is
yeah i've heard you even say you'll kind
of talk through jokes like while you're
doing dishes and stuff just in passive
time you'll also kind of be working out
i think about it all the time if i have
a new joke i'm constantly
it's running through my head and i'm and
i and so when i take it to the stage
it's it's almost already been done in my
head
a hundred times so it's not like i'm
like i'm not
totally reliant on the audience and i'll
put it in like the middle i
actually i open with a lot of new stuff
like i'm a big like with i have an
hour you know now doing an hour uh
i i open with uh usually new stuff
because i'm just so excited about it
that's something you gotta do when you
you start doing when you start
headlining and do an hour
you sometimes gotta move stuff around
because you get you're get tired of some
stuff
and so then you need to put new stuff in
front of that or
you gotta leave a new thing towards the
end just so you're excited
to get to that end yeah so you're not
because your energy will change once you
get past the new stuff
then you're just kind of like going
through the motion
you